[Music]
drex here from drexfactor poi sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're going to dive into some
anti-bridge transitions because i know
from the analytics on that video i
dropped a couple weeks ago that y'all
are hungry for it before we dive in i
just want to give a quick shout out to
the friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spinballs
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard lane
machinski and becca beckham thank you so
very much for your support for my work
and my mission
so
for a video that i literally just pulled
out of my butt at the last second that
video on antibrid alignments turned out
to be
really popular so i'm gonna capitalize
on that and i'm going to demonstrate a
combo for you all that utilizes the
knowledge that i was putting forth in
that video to give you a practical
application of many of those transitions
now it should be said that this is a
combo that is going to involve a lot of
both really really intricate tricks as
well as intricate transitions so i'm
going to call this intermediate to
advanced and you're going to need the
following tricks under your belt in
order to get it down the body tracing
hybrid known as the nevisol
a cat eye versus isolation anti-grid
the cap versus pendulum anti-bread
linear isolations
and stall chasers
i'll include links to tutorials for all
of these tricks down in the description
as well as up in the cards if you are
watching this video on youtube i'll show
you the combo at full speed then break
it down for you step by step before
showing it to you again in slow motion
[Music]
goodness so what have we gotten
ourselves into here um this combo starts
off of course with the nevisol which is
one of my favorite body tracing moves of
all time and one that i still do
constantly there's something about that
motion of having the hands running up
the body that i just absolutely adore
about this you know what else is really
cool about it if you stop your hands
midway up it you wind up in a crosser
now what's important about this being a
crosser is that it automatically puts
your hands in positions where they're
even with either shoulder just like you
do in the shoulder aligned antibrids
this transition is kind of subtle so i'm
going to show it to you from two
different angles
as we're going up with this nevisol body
tracing
hybrid
i want to take that midpoint where i get
about to my shoulders here and rather
than have my right hand poi cut behind
my shoulders i'm instead going to bring
it up and i can do this one in two ways
i can either have my right hand come
underneath my left or i can do a little
bit of a change and have my right hand
come up in front of my left
now
the line is going to be cleaner if my
right hand is in front but it also like
kind of a little bit breaks the spell of
that body tracing hybrid it looks less
like i'm trying to get into that if i do
have my right hand in front it looks
like i'm trying to do something
different there
if on the other hand i do keep my right
hand behind it means that i have to
unwrap and change the orientation of my
hands in order to get there
this might not turn out how you would
hope because it means that you have to
get your hands and poi moving around
each other in such a way that the
isolating poi that is the left-hand one
can go flying off very very quickly it
takes a it takes a a very very light
touch there here's what this looks like
from the side
so as i'm going up and going up
i have the option of right hand in front
to get to that position
or i have the option of
right hand behind to get to that
position do you see how even when my
right hand is behind i'm making sure
that my right hand poi is in front
and that gets me to the position that i
want to be in the end where my left hand
is behind my right hand
it looks like this
when you are doing it in front of you
one of the key changes that happens when
we make this transition is we get into
this spot where we have our hands and
poi even with our shoulders right
now
this is totally the alignment that we
want for isolation versus cat eye the
trick is that we have to really change
how we're thinking about the movement of
our hands in the process
rather than moving the hands in tandem
as they would in that hybrid we
immediately have to shift gears into
creating that poi head to hand alignment
that we have in isolation versus cat eye
this is easier if you know where you're
going to arrive to but
it is also somewhat of a challenge to
get your brain working in these two
different spaces so rapidly back to back
so we got to isolation versus cat eye
and it was lovely now we're going to
have to make our next transition going
from isolation versus cat eye to cap
versus pendulum now the good news is
here that we automatically have a spot
where this is not so terribly difficult
to achieve because of course our hands
are crossing our body center at two
different points in the hand path of the
isolation right
so as we're doing that isolation i
usually like to make this transition
happen when we're at the bottom here
when both of the poor are pointing down
and literally the only thing that
changes is rather than being in an
isolation at the bottom i just let the
poi kind of fall out into a pendulum
instead it's a little trickier with the
cat eye though because when i get to the
bottom i have to now start treating that
like the petal of an anti-spin in order
to get into this
cap versus pendulum spot here so from
here we're going to go ahead and switch
up the orientation of our cap we start
on bottom and we're going to wind up on
top once again it's still pendulum
versus cap i'm just doing my cap across
the top instead of across the bottom but
i'd still get these lovely moments of
contact between the hand and poi at
either end
trick is
i want to grab that moment when i have
my
cap hand that is my right hand going up
in the anti-spin right there as it's
going from right to left when that
happens boom i can now take both of the
poi into linear isolations let me show
you that one more time
i'm going back and forth and when i hit
the top point here you see how the two
poi are oriented as though they're in
split time same direction already i'm
just taking that momentum and pulling
them in center to complete the linear
isolation pattern now from our linear
isolations here our last step is that
when our hands go out to their native
sides it happens right here
i'm going to take that as a moment to
stall my right hand poi down and my left
hand poi up this is what puts me in
position to go back to doing hand
together
poi trick orientations here and gives me
a stall chaser to wrap the whole thing
up so let's look at all that from the
top all right so i'm going to do the
nevisol i'm going to do it three times
once
twice and then the third time boom i go
into isolation versus cat eye from here
i drop into cap versus pendulum
switch to the cap on top going back and
forth back and forth until boom i head
into my linear isolations and stop with
the poi out and go into
stall chasers
before finishing the whole thing off
let's check that out again in slow
motion
[Music]
now
cool i know this one is a challenge but
i think it looks particularly cool and i
hope that you do too so show me your
version of this please uh publish a
video of yourself doing this combo to
social media and make sure to tag me it
really makes my day when i see people
applying the stuff that i'm teaching out
there it really really really makes me
happy um so whatever platform you happen
to be on that is of your choice whether
it be like instagram tick tock
youtube facebook etc post your video
make sure to tag me i will come check it
out i cannot wait if you got anything
out of this video please make sure to
like comment share and subscribe both to
help other people find it as well as to
help my channel grow this video would
not be possible were it not for the kind
support of all of these wonderful people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
helped to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your wonderful
support do you like the videos that i
produce do you like my flow sessions do
you like my videos on flowers culture
and yes indeed my combo tutorials i'm on
a mission to try and bring poi spinning
and flow arts to the wider world and
help people connect with their bodies
and their brains so help me do it head
on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up there you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards
plus which you'll be helping me out in
my mission so go check that out please
and thank you do you have a particular
trick or type of trick that you'd like
to see me make a combo tutorial on leave
me a comment and let me know i'm always
down for a challenge and i have actually
made up a couple combo tutorials that
are built around specific tricks so
throw me your suggestions
i will go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of other combo tutorials that i
have done down in the description as
well as up on screen if you are watching
this video on youtube make sure to get
outside and flow this weekend and i will
see you with a brand new uh video on
monday see you then peace